وفي تصريح للجزيره قال وزير الطاقه
الاوكراني جيرمان جالوشينكو ان مستوى
انتاج الكهربائي في بلاده يغطي الاستهلاك
اضاف ان المناطق الاكثر تضررا هي تلك
الواقعه على خطوط المواجهه
في الوقت الحالي وليس لدينا عجز في
الانتاج انتاج الكهرباء يغطي الاستهلاك
لذلك هناك بعض القيود على الاماكن التي
تتلقى الكهرباء الاكثر تاثرا هي المناطق
القريبه من خطوط المعركه وبالطبع هناك بعض
الدمار لكننا نشعر اننا صمدنا بالفعل امام
تلك الهجمات لاننا نجحنا في الحفاظ على
النظام لم ارى اي هجمات مشابهه على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه ولا اعرف حتى كيف يمكن وصف
التحدي الذي نواجهه والمهم الان اننا نحقق
مزيدا من النجاح في ابقاء الشبكه في حاله
عمل وهو ما يمنحون المزيد من الثقه بشان
المستقبل